um the next list we're going to be
discussing is
[Music]
mine wow i guess we're just going in
order now all right
okay who [ __ ] needs it
i can't remember when i've last updated
this because i stopped updating my mao
and i
moved over the most recent and i moved
over to kitsu so it depends if kitsu
is also updating this but um
this is going to be my teenage uh taste
i'm guessing
i can tell this is your teenage taste
because like
i don't know in the past episode you
talked so much [ __ ] about akira and
you've given it an eight out of ten what
would you do
what would you give it now give it like
a six a six
what would you rate it today if i asked
you to rate i can make a kill like two
really two it's not that bad yeah i i
would also give it a second it's pretty
bad it's pretty [ __ ]
okay wait wait wait wait wait you gave
it a four you gave it a four okay okay
good
good yeah teenage me i'd say okay i
can't make a kill was one of those shows
where i thought was
awful and then all the comments were the
manga's better the manga is better
trust me guys the manga is better so it
was one of those few times
why i called them on their bluff right i
called the manga readers on their bluff
and i read the manga up to the end right
and i'm just like
this is just the same [ __ ] just
elongated you know what i mean
everyone was complaining about the anime
only ending of the karmico kill
but the manga is like equally as edgy
but it just it just elongates it just
has a different ending and it
it's it's it's equally as bad in my
opinion
you also rated alden uh zero yeah you
gave it a
six yeah you gave that season one to six
and and season two or six but season two
come on it's infinitely worse than
season one i don't know what i was
thinking
oh season one i don't know zero season
one it's actually like pretty decent i
think yeah yeah
yeah you've talked good of stuff about
al knows i i don't know
zero season one i don't remember why you
maybe finished both of them at the same
time like you maybe
because because i remember i'll know
season one being pretty
interesting and then like it it was it
was great and then the
cliffhanger season ending happened and
it was just like
holy [ __ ] this is super interesting and
then season two just kind of pissed on
everything that season one
became like kirito and stuff like being
the god of like yes
and i know i know this is like teenage
gods list because
okay one eight dude
okay okay i i still stand by that yeah
it is
it is but he also gave season two and
eight as well
season two is not as good as season one
i've i've never watched backer
what does bakker talk test about backup
it's just like a it's like a
comedy like kind of trashy like
romance to be honest i like it so i
thought it was really good
he was pretty good human ambassador for
domestic girlfriend he was right up his
phone
it was like one of the first comedy
anime that actually made me laugh and
i i didn't think was generic
and now that i look back i think yeah it
was probably pretty generic i don't know
like i look at the art style and i'm
just like this is premium mid-2000s
anime it is
nothing interesting to say about this
you gave uh baccano at 10 as well i like
that i like
that yeah i i think we all get back in
our attendance i guess if i didn't give
it a 10 on my list i don't know what
that's why that's why i'm curious to see
what your three by threes are because
that's that's where that's where like
the real personality test comes in hold
on i gotta ask it may lean
do we have beers oh no no navi gave me
some beers
we have beers okay good i'm just
checking i need to make sure okay okay
okay because it'll be fine oh no no we
we also oh yeah
we're going to be smashing some of this
yeah like [ __ ] the beers
no don't even he doesn't even deserve it
as well that you also gave uh batum an
eight
yeah joey gave batum a six yeah yeah i
actually would side more with god on
this one
even though it did end kind of [ __ ] yeah
wasn't the ending absolute [ __ ] but
the show was really fun and the show
opening was a bang
opening [ __ ] 10 out of 10. dude
[ __ ] 10 out of 10 opening yeah but
soon the show
that was just pure fun i don't know like
it is dude it was good
it was it was [ __ ] great it was one
of the few death games
that didn't feel like it was one a uh
battle royale rip-off right because the
problem with every death game anime
is that it feels like a like a virgin
battle royale you know what i mean
battle royale did it and like why would
you why would i want to watch anything
else
but zoom just it was just like it didn't
try to pretend that it wasn't a battle
royale rip-off
but it just like really it went off that
and it just was a hell of a lot of fun i
don't know i think i gave it a lower
score i think when i first
finished it i also gave her maybe like a
seven or an eight but then i read the
manga and i was like oh yeah compared to
that wasn't that great
i guess for some reason like batum has
always been one of those shows like
stuck with me i don't know why like i've
always just wanted the season too i mean
yeah yeah i always i i still think about
it and i still think about why
it didn't have a season two and like i i
know sydney read the manga and she said
the manga is also pretty good
yeah the manga the mung is way better is
it actually good yeah the manga is way
better
my brother because you gave gunk to
attend which i also agree with